he's an
Entertainer an
artist the star of a oneman
show the stage is always his calls
himself a lion sometimes he calls
himself the goat well now the biggest
ego in World sport meets well a
similarly proportionate ego on Center
Stage it's Zlatan Ibrahimovic
uncensored Zlatan how are you I'm good
thank you I can't think of anybody
better suited to do an interview for a
show called Piers Morgan uncensored than
you I think I'm the perfect guy for
you do you feel like you've always been
uncensored I feel
uh yeah I feel I've been myself always
even if people think I try to act or
something but I think I look I see and I
say so wrong and right I'm being myself
myself I think it's very important will
I get to the real you in this interview
100% you put the
level youve just retired yes something I
don't think you probably thought would
ever happen you worried about it
happening you were concerned about it
happening what's the reality been like
I'm I just retired three months ago and
uh I agree with you that if I want it or
or not is different but I accepted it
because in the end I was not feeling
good I could have continued I could have
continued suffering in physical way and
uh keep going but I wanted to feel good
and I didn't want to have a consequence
after my career where I'm limping or I
cannot do things with my boys so I
choose to to stop and I think I stopped
in the right moment but to be honest
with you when I see all the other
Strikers out there I could still play
because I I would do much more than them
and better than them and that's not for
my ego that's fact you want to name some
names I could give you many names
probably 95% of them out there so you
think you're better than 95% even now I
am better I don't
think i' take your I would take
your assle okay could be could be I had
a chance to go there but I know you
don't we're going to come to that it
breaks my heart I can't even think about
it um we're at the sh theater one of
London's great theaters here you're used
to being on the big stage this is one of
the big stages of theater it's an empty
crowd there's no one here yeah just few
people you should have brought me the
crowd well I wanted to see how you I I
would make them bounce you would you
would 100% how are you going to deal
with not having the big crowds being on
the big stage with a big crowd and now
now
this I think I don't need that I I've
I've been doing it for 20 years 25 years
I played in front front of
90,000 and uh I made him bounce I made
him chair I made him whistle I made him
hate I made him love so all these things
and uh I don't have that ego that I need
attention now because I am who I
am I'm remembered for what I did on the
field
so I'm not looking for attention I'm not
looking for get recognized and uh and
all those things because
or else I would choose to be a
commentator I would do those things that
you have these ex players doing
because they're doing it because they
still miss the attention they want to be
seeing in front of the camera and
um and I understand them because when
you're on the field you feel alive and
when you go there you get this
adrenaline you feel the grass you feel
the duels you feel the the heat you feel
the the atmosphere and then depending on
what kind of player you are I'm very
emotional player when I'm on the field
so I switch from one thing to another
thing and uh but now is a different
thing now I I will live a let's say a
normal life and uh hopefully a normal
life and what do you want to do have you
worked it out yet I have I'm doing more
I mean now three months has gone so I'm
doing more things now than I did when I
was active so I have my collaborations I
do different things things and different
projects I'm a little bit curious about
the acting thing
because I've been trying some things in
front of the camera I mean I'm not shy
if I'm a good actor I don't know I don't
think I can see you playing a James Bond
villain villain yeah yes I would smash
James Bond but he could win in the end
I'm okay with that but during the movie
I would smash him and then and then
probably I would lay
somewhere 2 m under the ground which is
okay because smile you smile you light
up the room you're very Charming you
seem a very nice guy when you when you
don't smile yes I look you have a very
severe face which I've seen on many of
football field you could be a good
villain I think I think also because and
for my English also I sound like a I
don't know criminal Russian type so
could be could be but I'm I'm interested
I'm I'm curious now like to see how it
works and and why not I mean just to try
some different uh different
things at your last game AC Milan
supporter is obviously going crazy for
you you made a very emotional heartfelt
address it was very moving actually and
at one stage it was interrupted by the
Verona fans booing you and you stopped
you stopped talking to your fans and you
addressed the Verona fans and you said
keep booing this is the biggest moment
in your year seeing me yes I love that
I me that was me being me exactly that
was me being me and
uh like I said you whistle you chair but
for them was the moment of the year
because seeing me is not for everybody
so that's the way they they enjoyed it
because remember if they whistle you or
talk bad about you it's because you're
number one did you play better when you
were in front of Home supporters
cheering you or when you were away
somewhere like into Myan where they
wanted to kill
I mean when you play on the highest
level you need to fight trigger points
because obviously after a while you get
used to one thing and then when you're
used to one thing you don't you don't
get triggered the same way obviously
you're a professional guy you go out you
do your
job but for me it was about getting
triggered I needed to get adrenaline and
playing home could be defense could be
the opponent I I needed to find trigger
points where I trigger Myself and I I
became more active but I have to admit
that I away games I feel alive I feel
very alive where the night let's say a
way against inter which is still my home
because it's my Stadium still and 90,000
whistling you I feel alive because I
feel with you Zlatan that your whole
life has been a fight yes and that's the
way you've actually liked it you were
brought up in a in an environment like
that you played football in that
environment you were at your best when
you were in a scrap and it was
interesting going over your life and
reviewing it you actually said you
viewed football as you viewed life it's
a fight you said and of course you're a
Taekwondo black Bel as well so you do
actually know how to properly fight I
need to be angry to play well you said I
need to shout and make some noise and
then your uh co-writer on your
autobiography uh David he said complex
is the best way to describe zlat on the
one hand he's a strong Warrior type who
knew he had to be very tough to survive
so he takes on fight all the time
because he's always had to but another
part of him is vulnerable he's a guy
wounded by his upbringing he uses all
that to create strength for himself in
his position 99 guys out of 100 would
have gone under but he used his anger to
make himself better that's true you
think that's an accurate I think it's a
correct picture of me
because even if I'm not in a fight I'm
looking for a fight
because it's something that kicks I get
a kick off I get adrenaline off and
where I came from it was about survival
mode I mean the the strongest guy would
survive and uh and to survive you need
you needed to be tough you needed to
show your tough and uh and that's where
I came from but I brought it in my game
also and
um and I had moments where it was going
against me moments where it was giving
me advantage and uh and all around me
was they were talking like it always is
Media they criticize you they talk
about you and uh and they they want to
have something to say but that was me if
I would would not be like that I would
not be where I came or maybe sit here
and speak to Pierce Morgan so will I get
a better interview out of you by being
nice to you or if I start yanking your
chain insulting you a bit roughing you
up a bit but I get the real Zlatan then
no you get you will get the real Z in
any any question I mean if you're
looking for something I will give it to
you if you if you
just keep it on a simple way I still
give it to you
because I have a lot of experience I
mean in front of
media I gave them they gave me but
I'm enjoying at that moment I think I
had moments where media
thought that I have some kind of acting
thing image because I want to do hard
hardcore image for the media and then
I'm soft on the on the inside but I'm
not afraid to say what I think I'm not
afraid to to to do what I believe in
then afterward afterwards they they give
you or
nothing I mean it's me I cannot change
me I'm not here to to be beautiful or uh
or to be perfect to somebody I think
being yourself is perfect you will do
mistakes you will learn from your
mistakes and you will still do mistakes
so I think is important being yourself I
came to America I
saw act no actors I saw
say big shots make trying to make the
perfect image and I go to one of the
show and they're like where's your crew
or Entourage and I'm like what about my
Entourage no but
normally like famous people they come
with 20 people I say you're here for me
or my Entourage for you I'm here so I
don't need them to make my image I'm
here for myself
so that's why I say I always say be
yourself being perfect is being yourself
and I think authenticity has a power to
it I think I think so yes and U me
getting angry and that that's me I need
I need to get fired up so that's how I
bring out sharpness that's how I bring
out the best out of me when I walk on
fire because if you make me feel too
comfortable
I'm playing to win and to win I will
destroy you I will do everything to win
and I need to win because when I win is
my is my proof that I am I am alive and
that's wherever I came I was like that
but then I had
some I had situation where I have
teammates they would cracking crack they
would not make it they would cry in
front of me but I don't care because I'm
here to win
because I played in top five clubs in
the world I played maybe three of them
and if I don't do my job they bring in
somebody else and I'm not there anymore
so that's why I say it's about survival
mode I'm not here to be nice or to be
bad I'm here to win so to win I needed
to to get those trigger get find those
trigger points to get the best out of me
I think to understand why you're like
this I want to take you back to to Malmo
uh to Rosengard where you grew up you've
described it as being like a ghetto it
was a rough tough place you said you can
take a guy away from Rosengard but you
can't take Rosen God out of a guy yeah
what do you mean by that I mean I can go
I can come I can make it out of the
ghetto but the ghetto will stay in me so
I came from Rosen because I am still who
I am even if I'm not there and that's
what I say you you can take yourself out
of a place but the the place you
were raised and and and born in it will
still be still be in you so
that I would never change for success I
would never change for whatever happens
to me I will still be the same guy
because the real the real thing will
stay and survive longer not because I
come in a nice area now I bought a nice
house in a nice area I become them no no
I'm still myself but my proof to them is
I can I can also live here even if I'm
from that area and I think is important
because you need to represent where you
come from but obviously then you need
discipline you need respect you need
education cannot be an animal in your
own where you come from and then animal
there you need
to you need to keep the discipline and
the respect which you said that where I
come from people were always judging me
and telling me no that's not possible I
want to show kids growing up like I did
that anything is possible I'm the living
proof you can succeed do you think
you've had that impact on young people
who were in your position
100% because where I came from with my
background if you look of the the
history like the in my game my football
game there were not a lot of players
with different background that would
make it or that would get the
possibility or the chance to just to
show themsel and and I'm happy that I I
went through all these walls just to
open the door for the Next Generation so
I open the door they have to step in so
I cannot talk for them I cannot uh prep
I mean do the things for them I just
open the doors and I had to go through a
lot of to come where I am and to show
everybody that it's possible and make
them accept also that it's okay whoever
you are to give you a chance then I talk
Sweden because that is my base then
obviously you become a global person and
and it spreads out because for me we're
all the same but still different so
all of us has the same possibilities to
make it but then it's up to you also
whatever you want to do tell me about
your parents um your father first of all
sephi he was a caretaker yeah um I was
interested that he he suffered quite a
lot of Torment as a result of the war in
Yugoslavia um it affected him quite
deeply I think have you ever had a
chance to really talk about that with
him no because he never spoke about it
with me I I had to so I was living with
my father we were like
five children my my my brother passed
away my big brother a couple of years
ago I have two bigger sisters that I
don't have contact
with h i have another bigger sister than
me that we have the same parents it's a
big mix yeah and we still have contact
contact and my little brother we we
still have contact today but I was
living alone with my with my father and
in the beginning was okay because I mean
the father he did every my father did
did everything to to survive to to bring
in money to to pay the bill to pay the
rent to make me feel happy he did his
maximum and the best out of the
conditions that was there and then the
war started
started then he was more distance from
me because he kept everything away from
me and uh and he took it very hard
because I remember like it's no secret
that my father was he drink and he was
sitting there with his
phone tried to reach out for the family
members I don't know what was going on
because I was pretty small at that time
and but but I could see and often what
you see stays longer than what you hear
so but we never discussed about it he
never put me in between he tried to help
family members so fugitives came to
Sweden family members and he helped them
and he put his name on it and
and I remember he was up during the
night and that always with the on the
phone and uh tried to help out but I
was I was young and I was crazy I was
wild I was out I was playing football a
lot I still had the discipline to go to
school because if I would not go to
school my my father would smash me which
is which is normal in our world so how
would he do that no he would he would
become aggressive he would he would make
sure I do it he would not hit me my
mother would hit me she was the one
hitting not my father my father I read
your mother used a wooden spoon wooden
spoon and hit me so when that would
break she would say to me go buy a new
one but I didn't break it you broke it
but was still by fault how many spoons
did you have to buy a lot a lot a lot
then it came to a certain moment like
how do you call the thing you put when
you press their bread like the round
when she came with that part
yeah yeah then I run away I said this is
too hard this you cannot touch me with
but for us was normal for us was normal
understand but it there'll be people
watching this who have not experienced
that from their parents do you feel that
you carried mental scars from the from
no being hit or not no it made me
stronger It Made Me Stronger because now
when I'm a parent myself I understood
what my parents went
through and
uh and he not easy I mean we live now in
2023 different conditions I live
different I can come with a suit
whatever for this kind of a
moments they couldn't they couldn't do
those things my mother had five children
she was a cleaner your mother she was a
cleaner she brought home
probably I don't know in pound like
let's say, Euro and to feed all these
five children and and she was working
from from 7 to 4: so we went to school I
have older sisters I had older brother
but my big brother was from my father's
side so he was not involved in my
mother's case and she had to feed
everybody and it was not easy and we
were all young crazy and wild so it was
not easy so that was her way to to put
the discipline on us but if I would go
back and say it's not okay no I would
say it was okay because it made me who I
am today and I understand in many eyes
is not okay but on under that conditions
different mentality different
approach they're from Balkan ex
Yugoslavia and and it's different
mentality and it's normal there in some
countries is not normal it's I mean you
can even Sue or whatever you say what's
your relationship like with your parents
today I'm closer with my mother with my
father it's it's it has been like it was
before before not so close as my mother
cuz he's two big egos to I am my father
so when he fights me he fights himself
which he doesn't understand because I am
like him he made me who I am so let's
say he he would come in my
garage and I have it's not secret I have
a lot of nice cars and he would said
what are you doing with those course
cars you you should sell them I said
listen you do your thing I do my thing
so
he triggers me he he he challenges me
but I am like him is he proud of you
though for what you've achieved yes he's
very proud because
when when I became professional
semi-professional in my team in Sweden
he started to he he had his living room
only pictures of me it was like a museum
so he got a new perspective in life to
follow me to he would give me even
advice how to play and he would say he
was good at the game but it's okay he's
still my father so I would listen but
still do my thing and he would be the
first one to to criticize me to
complain so even if I would
be let's say out of balance on the
field which he would also be he would be
the first one to say to me it's not okay
you need to have discipline you need to
respect the referees when I would attack
the referees you cannot do that and all
those things but he's talking to himself
now so but you learn he's a learning
process so there's a story I I love
about you and your dad that he bought a
a bed from Ikea to bring home and you
couldn't afford to for it to be brought
home for so you you both carried this
bed he carried the bed I had to carry
the the side things of it which was you
carried all the way back from my kid all
the way back so he would he would
say we went to buy bed because I said to
him Papa I'm growing I need a new bed
okay let's go buy it and we went to buy
it and uh it would cost money to
transport the bed to home and he didn't
have the money and I was like what do we
do now I carry it and he started to
carry it and he was walking and I could
see him getting pumped adrenaline
and and I was walk walking behind him
with the how do you call the side things
of the bed like yeah I know yeah
whatever and uh and I would slow down
because I was I was still small and not
strong as today so I would slow down and
he would get angry with me because I was
slowing down and he said hurry hurry and
uh and he was getting angry for me for
slowing down so I tried to catch him and
to stay with the same Rhythm but
obviously I couldn't because was heavy
but it took us one and a half hour to
come home to carry the bed so he would
do everything for me everything he also
paid he paid once gave all his salary
the bill he to travel to a training camp
even though he could barely pay the rent
so he made a lot of even though he was
this macho guy and that maybe gave you
that streak as well he was also a father
who tried to give you everything that he
could he gave me everything he gave me
everything and uh he even gave me more
than than he should because like you the
example you gave he paid my football
trip instead of paying his uh paying the
rent for our apartment so he would delay
it one two months and uh he just wanted
us to have good have but with discipline
with discipline mentality of the way he
wanted it to be what being do you think
the proudest he's ever felt for you in
your career he will not show it he will
not show it what do you think it might
be I
think me being on the big stage playing
my
game it's his moment of proudness
because I wear his last name
Ibrahimovic and I did one mistake when I
came to Ajax I don't know if you're
familiar with it I had lot
on my
shirt and I every time I met my
father he wouldn't say to me like he
didn't like it but I could see it but I
didn't understand because I was full of
adrenaline and when I was in the papers
when everybody would talk about me they
would say Zlatan Zlatan Zlatan so in my
head was Zlatan Zlatan it was not
Ibrahimovic so I say let's make
something difference why be like
everybody
else I put Zlatan and the first year and
I know on him he he was not okay with it
and then I say I bear
my I wear my last name and I continue to
bring that generation from
generation and I will bring it to the
next Generation in my boys so I changed
it to Ibrahimovic and uh and I think me
having Ibrahimovic on my back in the big
stage for him is a proud moment is a
very big proud moment and uh even if
he's strong macho guy he would not show
it because that's who he is I will give
you another example that I think not
many knows I came home I bought a car
for him said this is your car you I want
you to have it I want you to drive it
and that I don't need a car what what
was the car it was like a Mercedes
cclass cuz I said like big car you need
to look like the balcon type cool say
you drive around with it you're my
father and
uh and you should be proud and he said I
don't need a car and I said then now he
triggers me because now he's talking to
himself I said listen it's your car you
drive it and there is not a sub let's
say we we sit in a table I would say can
you hang me over the butter that would
be the polite way and I would say stupid
give me the butter but not to my father
to my sisters and brother so when he say
I don't need the cisen it's your car I
don't care you do whatever you want with
it and I throw the key on the
table and it's funny because after one
week I'm driving in the city and I see
that car I recognize a car and I say
that's a car I bought and I go close to
close that was him driving it so in
front of me he would not show it but
then when I'm not there he would he
would use it so is this proudness like
he's the bus under his roof so he would
say I don't need nothing from you this
is my roof I I am good as I am what
about your mother you have a better
relationship with her a closer one with
her closer how's her life now what have
you been able to do for her I mean you
bought her a lovely home I think didn't
you I bought a lot of stuff which is
normal you Tred to help
out what I
understood fast quick in my in my life
when I became successful was I will help
you but I will not interfere in your
private life because I'm not the one to
choose for you or change you but I will
help you I will make it easier for you
so that that had changed very fast so I
help everybody I made it easier for
everybody but under condition still you
have
to work for yourself because I don't
want to change your life I said to my
father you are who you are before and
you will be who you are afterwards also
you cannot become who you are and then
become a rockstore because I help you
because from a rockstore what do you
become come and then when I stop and
there's no more helping what happens
then then you go back from Broar to then
you become depressed you change your
life so I help you I make it easier for
you so my mother let's say I gave
everybody a home which is standard
because everybody should have a home and
live good and then I I always say
because my image because I say image
stays longer than the than what you hear
here so when I was I grew up I had an
empty fridge which is not a
secret I always make sure they have a
full fridge because that when I moved
together with my with my Helena I said
listen the only demands I have from you
that the fridge has to be full because
every time I open the fridge I want it
to be full even if I will not take
something out I just want to take away
that image where it's empty and I have
milk I have cheese I have ham and
nothing more and I want to take out that
image from my ra when I was raised and
have a full fridge even if I would not
pick up something and and I make sure
they have full fridge and and an extra
penny in the pocket so whenever you need
something in Emer emergency case you buy
but don't go out and buy spend if you
don't just for fun because it's not the
way I totally understand that did you
feel as you grew up that you had love
from your parents even if they had a
strange way of showing
it I think we show love in a different
way in my family we show Love by
aggression we show love in a hard way we
are not the ones we clap you on the back
we hug you we we hold you around that is
not the way we show love we have a more
rougher
environment you were bullied when you
were young you said I was a small guy
had a big nose had a lisp I speech
therapy a woman came to school and told
me to pronounce the letter S I thought
it was humiliating I had to prove myself
you were hungry as you've just said you
began to steal a lot of things bikes
Suites cars everything and anything you
said um one day you stole the postman's
bike that was a great bike a military
bike you said um you could have I guess
like a lot of people in that world you
could have just continued down a life of
crime maybe ended up in prison or Worse
dead do you think about that Crossroads
in your life the football gave you the
way out I think football it
it it rescued me because obviously where
I came from there is right side no you
go right side or you go left side and
you choose what you want but I think
with my father with the discipline
because every time I did something
stupid and he would know about it he
would let me know and he would let me
know in his own way so that gave me a
little I I was scared about it but at
the same time I contined to do it
because I wanted to do things I wanted
to have things like the other ones had
and I didn't have things like my my
friends have like the people in school
had so and I did it in my own way
because I couldn't get it from my from
my father because I was raised up by by
my father so he made me scared of
doing stupid things but still I did it
because it it triggered me and then
football
I always played football because my
mental where I came from we played
football we played football and the
mentality was I'm the best he uncensored
the rest so that was my mentality and my
my motto so everything I did I wanted to
be the best and playing football playing
football and then one day my father said
let's
go play or try in in the higher level of
football we and I came there and they
took me in straight so football was
always my main thing even if I did all
these things around around the stupid
things which which I think many many
many does but I speak for myself so have
you ever met any of the people that
bullied you yeah many of them I think I
was more bullied by the media than than
people around me really if I'm honest
but the one the ones who bullied you
when you were young you've met them
since you were successful I've seen them
but I haven't
really really talked to them because
friends friends come and go
because you have friends when you're
young but you will understand who your
real friends is when money come in the
picture what do you feel though about
those bullies do you feel I showed you
or do you feel
anything you know what everybody has a
dream to become something if we share
the same dream I cannot I don't have any
hate for that person because if we share
the same dream we believe in the same
thing and then I make it you don't make
it and you treat me bad when you were
young I cannot dislike you it's the same
thing now on the field if I fight with
somebody if I don't like somebody on the
field I cannot hate that person because
we share the same dream but is the best
revenge
success in some moments yes because like
I describe my anger when I do things
let's say the media attack me the
they they call me they say stupid things
about me they they say things because
remember I played when you didn't have
digital platforms so I could not
react like the way we can react today
because you can do whatever you just use
digital platform you get your saying on
on my time I had to wait I had to wait
until I see next time that person and I
would say it in his face or I would
catch him and I would do something there
and there was no limit there have you
actually have you hit journalists no but
I've been close by to to have that anger
to hit them but I didn't come so far
because I was always like it will come
back to me what would annoy you the most
that the media would say about you I
mean when it becomes personal I had
moments where they would say personal
stuff about me Judge Me by where I come
from the way I look the way my style was
the way I show my love
because I didn't show my love by hugging
people I was
very very aggressive as a type when I
was young and but that didn't mean I
want I want bad I want to do you bad I
want something bad to happen to you that
was the way I was was the family
upbringing you had was my family well
the upbringing you had was that you
showed love in a different way that love
was quite they didn't understand me the
thing is they didn't understand me and I
was not there to explain them who I am
or or whatever I was but when it came
moment
like I had certain moments where it they
would put out a a thing outside like
stupid thing like I would look for a
girl I'm 190 tall you want to win
whatever with me and that that's still
in my head and this happened 20 years
ago so it's not okay you don't do those
things because I was fighting to survive
I was fighting to to be successful to
make it the maximum what I could and you
had these these people pushing me down
and and or pulling me down and
just and just being in my way but I
think also that may be stronger because
I am who I am in every situation and I
will say what I think and what I believe
in then if you're right right or wrong
listen it takes two persons to to
discuss not one you said the two most
important people in your life uh one was
your great friend and longtime agent
Amina Rola
who died last year yes that must have
been a huge blow to you I I lost my
agent several years ago suddenly in his
50s same thing and he was a one of my
closest friends knew everything about me
I mean it's a very unique relationship
you have what what impact did his death
have on you it was a big loss it's still
a big loss and uh and I still miss him
today and uh and I will miss him forever
because he was not only agent for me he
was everything my career started when I
I moved to Ajax but my real career
started with when the first day I met
him and uh and we did everything
together the football outside football I
shared every moment with him happy
moments bad moments and uh and even in
my private life I would present
him a girl and I would say what do you
think is for me or not he would say yes
or no so he was involved in everything I
did but but really everything and uh and
when that tragic moment happened to me
last year I
was it was not the same thing football
became different for me and and in
everything I do
because everything we did was was
sharing moments obviously I became older
he saw me grow from a baby to a man I
became who I am because of him also and
uh and we would challenge each other all
the time he would give me so much I
would give him so
much and we would go in fights but hard
fights and uh we would swear each other
we would we would say nasty things to
each other and like then I would say
like you you don't work for me anymore
you fired and he would be to fire me you
need to hire me so he would always
trigger me like that see and I would
leave the leave the room and he would
say you too and never call me so was ha
and love but the hate was actually love
because if if you really like somebody
you're open you're direct and you would
say anything but would not change
anything between the the two persons so
I took it very hard and my game would
not be the same because I'm doing things
now on my own not the with somebody
which I would always do because before I
do something I would call him what do
you think so this interview would be
Mino what do you think and he would say
he would say yeah go destroy him or go
make him
famous we would disc this guy he would
give which one are you going to do here
no I'll make you I don't know you're
you're big shot so I'm not worried about
you so no he would be positive he would
he likes he likes the challenge he
doesn't he's a he was an agent that was
working for the player he was not
working for clubs he was working for the
player and he
would he would change the player's life
that was his aim he had some players
where I would say you don't need him
he's waste of time he said no no I need
I need to change him I need to let's say
save him what was the best advice he
gave
you he always said to me be happy and
enjoy for what you do because he
wouldn't see me always happy he wouldn't
always see me enjoy in what I do so his
motto was like happy and enjoy which is
difficult because the person I am I'm
never satisfied because I always want
more and
uh and like I said I needed this kind of
anger on the field
and and like you did like you said
before like to bring out the best out of
me you described me before bring out the
best of me I needed to find these things
so Mino would say because he knows me he
knows me perfect when I didn't want to
go to a club he knew exactly how to
guide me versus whatever he want because
he had a vision he he saw the the the
future before it it like it happened he
knew we would stay short time in let's
say in Barcelona but not because to make
money which would sound and make sense
we change commission whatever you make
no he would say after a short way he say
you don't fit in here this will last
short he he would say when I move from
Milan they cannot they cannot pay
anymore it's like it's like sinking and
then he he would say in Paris we go to
Paris because that project only you can
you can change that project then when we
would leave it's finished so he had this
Vision when before it before it happened
he he he said it and he would say
like we need to create problems we need
to make problems and I would say why
because we are we are at the best when
we have problems because we need to
solve it when things are
normal it's not okay because we are not
normal we're above normal so so he would
he would trigger me in that way I say
okay tell me what you want you be the
bad guy be the nice guy so when we would
change Club he say you go and you say
some words we open the door then I go
and I be the soft guy so we would we
would play the game good cop bad cop yes
but the thing is he would be the bed cup
because if he doesn't get what he wants
chairs are flying tables are flying and
I would say like listen the deal you can
break the deal I don't give a and I
would say listen don't do that listen
you focus on yourself I focus on me you
do your thing I do my thing so yeah yeah
he would he would put the wall between
us
and it's your problem not mine like like
this we would trigger so when it
happened was a big loss because he was
like like a role model for me Father
friend agent
example and
uh yeah I learned a lot about from him
so like I said I still miss him we all
miss
him the other you would enjoy with him
100% I I met him once very briefly this
interview uncensored you would he was a
great character agent everyone knew that
and I'm very sorry for you that you lost
such a close friend um the other person
you said was the most important of
course is your partner Helena uh she was
an economics graduate uh she was a
successful former children's television
presenter 11 years older than you and
you meet uh at Malmo train station
outside of buo Des and her first
impression wasn't great Zlatan no you
were 20 she thought you were pretty rude
pretty cocky a bit of a a bit of a Yobo
you turned around how did you manage to
convince her you weren't her worst
fears I mean I didn't give up because I
saw this blonde blonde girl and I was in
my in my Ferrari I wanted to act cool be
cool but she had a pretty cool car also
so and I parked the car and I was like
listen try to be cool and she saw me she
was ignoring me totally and I was like
like that was not the response I wanted
to have and uh and I was shy when I was
young I was shy because I wasn't
feeling I wasn't feeling the guy I am
today let's say
because when I came first time in the
city I was 18 years old I did I didn't
know about these blonde girls because
where I came from we have we had a
different backgrounds so we're different
type of U of persons girls so when I
came in the city suddenly saw all these
blonds I saw who different movements
which I didn't know it exist because I
was never in the center because I was
always where a in my in my neighborhood
then I saw this Helena and I was like
beautiful girl wow wow wow she ignored
me totally and I was like that's not
okay and I knew a friend that knew her
and I was sending message she was like
ignoring me there also but I didn't give
up and I think when you don't give up
you you reach out and in the
in the end I got a possibility and uh
but the funny thing is in that message I
sent her the first
message I
wrote a storytale whatever and then I
finish with the red one so she would
know who it is and the red one was my
red Ferrari because like yeah and she
would answer and she would say with the
black one because her sport car was
black I was like okay and then from
there we started to talk get to know
each other but she was 10 years older
than me 11 years older so I was a little
child for her I was like
unmature little for her so she was this
elegant moving around good knew what she
was doing knew what she
want and date date date and I think we
we dated for for for two years then when
I moved to to Italy I say listen it's
time to come over and let's try you
never know what how it will be what will
happen and uh and I had to say if she
would wouldn't be 11 years older than me
I don't think she would hold out because
like I said I was very
wild a different way of showing my love
I had a different temperament and uh but
she had a lot of patient and I think
because of the age she's still there
today
because she being more mature than me
and having patient
or she or she saw an investment in me
maybe she might want have seen it she
saw the future she might have seen a
better you down the line right I mean
you said she understands my character
and accepts I'm a bit crazy I was
surrounded by chaos when we met I was
out of control I'm Cal her today maybe
she realized she could calm the Beast
could be could be I mean like I said the
age I think made a difference because
and then you get to know each other
obviously I think a partner every five
years Chang I don't think you're with
your wife you have the same wife like
the first day you met her is not the
same you don't actually have a wife you
never actually because I don't want to
lose
50% you have two children I don't have
have two I have two boys I think why why
have you never asked her to marry or
have you
H I have and what happened she said no
really yes so she strong eh when was
this this was a couple of years ago
because I said after 20 years you
deserve to be married with me she said I
don't I don't need to be married with
you to be with you she's strong she's
very strong how did you feel about being
rejected I think it's cool because if
you do that you you gain more respect
for me because I don't have to win all
the time are you going to keep
trying no she had one chance she will
not get a second chance but she has two
boys from me so that's even even bigger
than being married is it true that um
when asked what You' bought her for a
Valentine's Day gift you replied what do
you mean present she got
Zlatan that was another girl that was
not my another girl yeah yeah you
wouldn't try that with Helena that was
not Helena because she will step out of
the door the straight that was another
one so when everything happened around
me a lot of adrenaline a lot of media
tension every day was a was a was
a highlight of me in the Press so I was
like this adrenaline needs to continue
and my friend was like and I met this
girl and uh and I asked
to how do you say
to how do you say to not marry but you
the first step is you engagement
engagement and she said yes and uh and
was cool because was adrenaline but I
didn't really understand what it meant
because within one year you need to get
married and I said no no I don't want to
to get married but I got a kick of it
like I have a ring I have a girlfriend
I'm engaged then the media said what
what kind of present journalist said
what what do you mean present she got me
she don't need a present so that was it
engagement gift I was the gift and then
you broke off the engagement brazili
then after when I was told you need to
marry within within one
year the next day I broke up because I
said I don't want to marry I I was like
I didn't do it to marry I did it because
was I thought I was cool so I didn't
understand I was young and I didn't but
do you think Helena saying no to you was
was payback then for the for the no no
no no she don't care about the past she
was like listen I don't need to marry to
show that I'm I'm together with you and
uh and uh we have two boys and and to be
honest I don't need a piece of paper to
to show that she's mine she She's Mine
whatever paper we we have Among Us I'm
told she doesn't allow you to have any
pictures of yourself on the walls she
said none I have none just a picture of
your
feet but that's my idea because the
family has to remember where all these
things comes from where all the food
comes from it's because of my feets so
it's a reminder for them every time they
step in my gym they see these Feats so
what about your
head the feet magic but the head I mean
shouldn't you have a picture of your
head somewhere no because because of my
Feats yeah but my head controls the
feets you're right
but also you scor some great goals with
your head I mean nah no no my feet talks
more for my for my game The Heading came
in the end when I was not fast enough
but no he a reminder and it's a cool
picture but the mostly it's a reminder
where where everything come from so not
to forget why we
are where we are because of what so but
actually no pictures of me because she
says I've seen so many pictur and also
for my kids because my kids I am a
father for them it's important for me to
see me as a father and not
the the the professional player
Ibrahimovic
because they should not grow up grow up
in uh in my in my shadow shade let's say
because they are more important than me
and uh and they will never come in a
situation where they feel second or
third they are in pull position so it's
very important with for me this would
you want your boys to play Elite level
football having been through all the ups
and downs you've been through yeah yeah
why not they choose themselves I mean
they're playing football today they play
for Milan and they do they're very
focused and and the important thing they
don't do it for me because I see a lot
of parents now when I have boys I bring
them to the the game football but also
different kind of sports I see they push
their
kids they they oblig them to do things
and uh because you have this problem
because everybody in the world now think
because football is a is a biggest sport
in the
world ER they make a lot of money to
doing to do little they make a lot of
money so these parents they invest a lot
in their kids so suddenly they're not
parents they're coaches they're agents
they're lawyers they're everything
because they see the possibility in
their kids but what they don't
understand you cannot transform the kid
to do it for you they have to do it for
themselves and I'm lucky in my situ no
not lucky I guided this way that they're
doing it for them all for for them
themselves how do you give them the
hunger that you had given they're not
hungry I treat them like they would be
my teammates I don't treat them like
they're my boys if that is okay or not I
don't know but I treat them like they
would be my teammates I'm direct to them
tough love very tough very tough I I
judge them like I would judge my
teammates not my boys so I'm I'm honest
I'm direct and I push them push them
high but they choose if they want to do
it it's not like I tell you I oblige you
to do it like I would bring them to to
training let's say we were living in La
which you are familiar about the traffic
there is not a is not a normal traffic
you go and I drive one and a half hour
to bring them to training and I said to
them you do 200% in training because me
bringing you to training I do it for you
not for me I could do something else but
you give 200% or else I'm not doing this
but in the end you're doing it for
yourself because every time you step on
the
field when players get angry for Co at
coaches teammates or whoever surrounding
all media they forget every training
they do is not for the surrounding you
do the training for yourself you do it
to become better and make a better
version of yourself and test yourself so
I get I tell them you give 100% if it's
a good or bad training can happen but
you do it for yourself and you give 200%
because I have other things to do and
and I push them so
hard that they they do the best and more
than that they cannot do then if they
become professional or
not people think it's easy it's not easy
because everybody think hey I train I go
do individual skills I don't go do that
I get an agent I get this coach and I'll
become a pro doesn't work like that it's
it has to be about luck hard work where
you come it's meant that you should be
where you are and it's easy to say hey I
could have been a pro I would be the
best in the world no it's not like that
it's all this combined and then we see
what happens they have to be happy
healthy healthy but with discipline they
have to do the things because my
philosophy is why be normal when you can
be the best I don't want to be normal I
want to make the difference so
everything I do I want to make the
difference because when I make the
difference I'm the best and that is not
arrogance that is confidence for me your
tal your talent has made you extremely
wealthy do you know how rich
you I always say money is not important
you are agree with me or no I think it
can be important no no yes or no well
here I no no I just want to yes or no
then you explain what's the question
money is not important money is
important I'll tell you why no not
having a lot of money wait wait a lot of
money is important I think removing no
no I think I would say that removing the
worry about not having money is
important in other words the stress that
many people feel from not having enough
money just to get by I think that is a
terrible stress so having enough money
where you you have security and comfort
in your life I don't think you need to
have
gazillions I think when it comes to
money I always they that that was a joke
that I was saying because when I say
money is not important people would
always say no no money is not important
then I would say a lot of money is
important because me and me always when
we do
things a lot of money is important so it
was more not to have the money it was
more a trigger thing a challenge because
obviously you have a successful company
you don't want to sell it low you want
to sell it maximum as possible but not
maybe not to survive or to have it just
for the challenge because you create
something and then you get a big Jackpot
by selling it high and I agree with you
money creates problems even in families
money brings stress the more you have
the more stress and and where is the
stop you could live a good life with
normal money but what is normal money
now I've been on the both sides I've
been without money grew up with a family
where my father made, EUR in pound I
don't know how much it is and still we
had a good at that thousand EUR over
what period monthly monthly monthly
thousand then you pay bills and that I
don't know how much is left and uh and
we have to share it not share it it was
his he gave me whenever I needed and uh
but I had a good life I had it good at
that moment so were you happy where is
the stop were you happy then but what is
happiness well you tell me it's moments
I'm happy now in 10 minutes I could be
unhappy so it's
moments uh money makes it easier makes
your life easier but I don't think it
gives you happiness because for me
happiness is moments you're happy with
one situation
now my dream was come to Barcelona after
one year was my nightmare yeah so it's
moments but I agree with you I think
when it comes to having a lot of money
it's a ego thing because you your life
would not change let's say the Saudi
situation now a player that made a lot
of money goes there to make even crazy
more money does it change your life
because I will tell you you will die
before you waste your money you already
earned than the money you get in Saudi
so it will not make a difference you
must have had a big offer to go to
Saudi I had an offer also from China I
had offer also from uh from from Saudi
but the situation is what do you want
what is
your what objectives do you have I said
before we started like certain players
need to
finish his career in big stage because
that is like the high end of your career
because you have to be remembered for
your talent not for what you earned
because if you be remembered in opposite
way what we are training every day for
what we are being
recognized for is our talent and that's
what you want to be remembered for so I
think certain players that reach a
certain level they have to stop in a
certain stage and that's the big stage
you cannot go in a lower stage and and
finish your career in a different way
but some players needed the the
situations where you can earn a lot of
money because they didn't earn enough
how much have you turned down to play in
Saudi I mean in
Saudi no I had a bigger offer in China I
had a 100 million offer in China but I
and I went to America because I got
injured and the situation change but I
turned it down before I went there
because it's not what I wanted and I
would instead of getting a lot of money
straight I
would I would challenge myself to arrive
there by different different ways of
coming to
there but the challenge to get it not
because I needed or because I wanted
would you have any moral problem in
playing in Saudi Arabia no no what would
no absolutely not I mean you have the
golf situation now they they came
together and they made it made it one so
I'm just sorry for the players that
didn't go before because they didn't get
the money that the players got it so no
the football listen wherever you play
football it's football football connects
people like it's a dream we share both
of us you were a fan you were not a
professional you're an Arsenal fan and I
feel sorry for you a little bit but as a
professional football player as long as
you play football and and Saudi is
growing MLS is growing I mean China had
a peak and then I don't know the
situation changed there but a moral
thing no no we are still I mean we do
things for ourself and our our family
who would judge you in five 10 years
when you have a healthy wealthy healthy
life and have a good life
because I don't think nothing is for
free you don't work for free I don't
work for free I don't need money but I'm
very expensive that's the difference if
you were to fall over dead tomorrow how
much would you be
worth I mean I
have I don't we have to talk Valuta now
because we have crones we have dollars
we have give me any any currency you
like US dollars
here lies Zlatan he was
worth I don't know I don't know probably
half half a billion yeah half a billion
US Dollars yeah but it's not important
for me because I don't care about it
because if I die tomorrow what what
understand no no I understand you but
I'm thinking Next Step it's not
important my point did the kid in Malmo
on those rough Streets Could you ever
have imagined no ever that one day you'd
be worth half a billion dollars
no no and what does it feel like it
didn't change me because I'm still who I
am and I will not probably see those in
front of me like Mayweather he has
everything in front of him I have
everything mine in digital numbers
so it makes it easier for you but like I
said it's not important for me because
it doesn't trigger me I still get angry
I still get aggressive even if I'm in
that situation so I need to feel alive I
need to do different things you talked
earlier about having this dream of
playing for Barcelona and it did turn
out to be a nightmare and probably the
main reason for that was the breakdown
in your relationship with the manager
Pep Guardiola who right now many would
say is the best coach in the world you
had a very different experience with him
uh you called him a coward with no balls
uh you said when you buy me you're
buying a Ferrari if you drive a Ferrari
you put premium petrol and a tank you
hit the motorway and you step on the gas
guarda filled up with diesel and took a
spin in the car Countryside he should
have bought a
fat I think Guardiola is an amazing
coach when I was there the coaching was
different compared to what I had before
he totally on a different level that's
why he's successful because if you see
on his
career if you take the last 15 10 to 15
years the guy never came third place
he's always first or second so the coach
is amazing and uh but I had a different
situation with him because I had the
coach and I get to meet the person and
we it became a problem a problem I I was
not aware of because I solve my problems
I look in the eyes doesn't mean I have
to like you or dislike you we will solve
it and it takes one second to solve it
we go straight and we solve it but solve
a problem if the problem is between two
persons it takes two to to solve it and
especially when the other side doesn't
know when I remember when I was there I
was was like because before I came to
Barcelona always media have their input
and saying they would go like you don't
fit in here you don't fit in the culture
it's different different because who I
was and my mistake was there I try to
fit in instead of being who I am because
I think is important like I begin the
interview being who you are is being
perfect but there I tried to be somebody
I was not and I said to him listen you
if I have two big noes for you you tell
me if I walk strange you tell me if I'm
not good enough you tell me if you don't
like whatever I do you tell me I resolve
the problem I leave I'm not here to
disturb I'm need I'm not here to create
I'm just here to F fulfill my dream and
uh and I didn't hear nothing about it
the the thing was it kept kept first six
months was okay everything was good no
but the strange thing the first meeting
I had with him was like
remember players here don't come with
Ferrari Porsche and that then it it felt
like why he's already judging you but
why you call me every day to bring me
here and then you want to send this
message to me don't worry I will not
bring my car and I didn't bring it
didn't bring it for six seven eight
months and then I started
to the directors because I I would
perform bad and the the people above him
would complain but they said we cannot
engage if you don't open the door so I
would have to go to him and say listen
what's going on so I create a situation
so the people above him could interfere
because they could not interfere if
there was nothing and I went to him
listen can I talk a friendly talk like
simple even I wrote it in the in the
book I say I said to him listen I'm not
doing good I think with the situation
with mess see putting him I need more
space you brought me in so I need my
space to do my thing because the way you
want me to play now is not I'm not good
enough then better you put the other
players so I was direct and open and we
spoke normal normal conversation because
I never had a problem with a coach in a
professional way so the case with him
was the first time I
had I had not discussions because we
didn't even come there like a problem
without knowing problem and he said in
the endend which was cool don't worry I
take care of this I was like okay cool
everything is done next game I'm know
I'm on the bench said okay no problem
and I'm not the type that would go to
the coach why am I not play why am I not
playing you should play me cuz remember
I come
from hard work you get what you work for
so for me working hard I would get and
not I need to play I want to play cuz
it's not how I get my my my proof of
playing because I prefer you hate me but
I play then I know why I play because
I'm good second game
bench third game bench said okay and now
I'm getting pumped up because obviously
I need to do more to show
myself but I noticed it was not about me
performing anymore it was I think my
opinion he felt offended for me saying
to him I needed more space and the way I
wanted to to play he punish which is
okay yeah which is okay he's the coach
bad results he leaves player stays and I
respect that but be open to me be direct
to me so we understand each
other fourth game bench and then I
started to make noise because it's not
okay for me anymore now I'm on the bench
and I have on I'm on the bench because
of a s situation I created not by my own
ER how do you say by my own choice
because because of the people above him
because for them I was a big
investment and the fourth game I bring
my Ferrari and I bring the end of
Ferrari and I knew it would create
another situation so I parked the car in
front of his office so you with me I
with you that was my motto you parked it
in front of his office in front of his
office I said this
is you want to play with fire I'll bring
you fire but I will burn you but
obviously he's the coach because what
punish most the players player if he
doesn't play because obviously you want
to play but the boss is the coach but in
that moment I understood this will not
be okay because there is something how
did he react to you parking your Ferrari
outside he would not say nothing to me
because he would avoid me but then they
came the strange thing is I would go in
a in the breakfast we have a breakfast
area where both of us would come I go in
he would go up and go out of the
room on the field he would never connect
with me like this because you can
connect
by passing each other then you start to
talk without looking for it because I
can pass you on the street oh what's up
P everything okay you know you
understand so we would go against each
other he would take a whole round and go
around me and then I noticed something
was more than just the player because
was too strange is that why you used the
phrase cow but no balls yeah because he
would not confront his whatever problem
he had and he would use his right guy to
resolve H his problem and probably he
would say now I don't talk about it and
is him still have it in the head him
still talking about it when this will
come out but you give me the question
and I answer your question so he need
not me still think about it it's me only
answering it came to a head there a
dressing room incident after Bara lost
inter uh and it's alleged that you threw
a training kit box across the room yeah
guard is that true versus him yeah did
you hit him no he didn't hit how did he
how did he react it was a message no he
stepped out of the lockum he would not
confront me he will not confront me like
I see him because I follow football I
see him in the press conferences now and
that saying his thing this didn't happen
here so maybe
become bigger man now spoken to him
since he left no no we
met we met uh when I was in United he
was obviously in
city so you pass the
players but I would not see him there
and this is not me looking for him or
something because for me is the P
because what happened happened you
cannot go back and change you grow from
that you become different from that you
get experience from that but what I know
his his closest friend would stay out of
the out in the hall and wait for me to
pass and and when I pass he would come
out and the funny thing is if I would
see him nothing would happen because for
me I'm a man I take it as a man if I
have a problem I resolve it if he's
watching this interview what would you
say he would say I still think about it
still I I am crying no I think he's
amazing coach don't get me wrong I think
he's amazing coach what he's doing he
changed the game 100% he's being very
successful as a man as a man I see him
do some press conference I see him he
has been stepping up
so he not he not the one I know I mean
that I met so I'm happy for him I mean
remember we share the same dream we work
I was a professional player he was a
professional player so I don't want any
harm for him dislike or
like still we we we share the same dream
you cannot hate a person because of the
situation like that he thinks about him
I think about me so like I said he's a
coach I'm a player so I think about me
he think about him he has his
responsibility I mine the difference is
I resolve my problem if I have a problem
so if he would say to me listen your
nose is too big listen is the last time
we meet you're not happy I go I resolve
it but I didn't know that's my still
until today I don't know what what the
problem was you think you should have
the courage to tell you no he shouldn't
he should run
away one coach you loved was Jose
Mourinho and you had great success with
him what was it about Jose you you said
I think that Jose when he when he comes
in a room the lights go on whereas
Guardiola pulls the curtains back first
time I met Jose I mean first time Jose
presented himself was when he won the
Champions League with the with Porto and
then he came to England and he made a
lot of noise but you walk like you talk
no he did everything he said he would do
and for me that triggers me because that
is not arrogance for me that is not you
think you're something that for me is
confidence he really believes in it and
and he's outspoken and I'm and I'm the
same I believe in certain things and I
will say it and I will do everything to
reach to my objectives and I met him
first time in
inter and it was all it was all
different because I came from Capello
and capella
was was old school but very hard the
mentality he
he he smashed me every day he brought me
down then he pulled me up he brought me
down he pulled me up so he created my
mentality on the field because he never
made me feel satisfied and he put me in
front of the goal and he said I need
this from you bom and we were shooting
shooting and some trainings I try to
hide myself so I would hide myself among
canaval Patrick viea and all these big
players because I was the young guy like
just to go home and he would scream my
name ibra that was when my nickname came
out so he would scream and I was like
and I would go back to the field and we
would train extra for one hour shooting
shooting but that was fun but was hard
for me because I did it every day so
that was old school uh mentality and the
way of working then I met Mourinho what
which
was hardcore ality but new new thing
like every training we would do
something new we would never repeat an
exercise twice so he would divide the
fields in four four areas so we would go
from every area so everything was new
and he would sit in front of the team
and he would say Direct in our face
listen you will all get a chance if you
would get a second chance no so he was
direct to everybody in that but the the
thing thing with Mourinho is he makes
you
feel so strong that you go out and you
fight for
him and you do whatever it takes to win
so he's like a like a teacher which he I
think his background is also a teacher
so he would he would motivate you on
High level that you would do anything to
go out and as a as a man no he's cool
he's cool he's direct he's direct and
he's he's a winner he's a winner and
he's he says what he thinks and but he's
very well informed before he goes into
something he would know about me more
than I would know about me before we
start to talk just like you said before
you know more about me than I know about
me so as a man no no he he's cool you
scored over 500 goals uh you played over
100 times your country and you're that
Sweden's top scorer what's your favorite
goal if I could relive a moment would it
be the bicycle kick against England yes
because it was Eng I tell you why
because of many reasons because the goal
is amazing I mean the goal for
me not because it's me not because of my
ego who would do that thing I don't see
many players do that thing because many
players in that situation we winning 32
it was the last minutes would take down
the ball and waste time because you want
to win the game
obviously but when I saw the moment I
said heart was a goalie and I said I
will fool him now when I saw him run out
I will pretend to go forward towards him
then I will back off because I know by
experience you go through towards
somebody he will just head it and it
will go far out but I will do opposite I
will pretend to go with him so a certain
point you will see me slow break slow
down then go back then it was all about
where the ball comes because I don't
know and then I took it instinctly from
there like turn around and as a striker
you know where your goal is you don't
need to see the goal you can put me in
every angle on the field I will know
where the goal is because as soon as you
hit the ball with the bicycle kick you
knew it was going I knew already where
the goal was the let's say and did you
know when you hit it it was going in yes
you could feel it yes the only tricky
was here I needed to change my angle
body angle versus the goal so I could
not let's say bicycle kick so if you
want to kick it straight with a bicycle
kick it goes straight back so the only
thing I needed was to change my angle
body where the goal is and I knew where
the goal is so I just needed to change
and I know the goal is there and now
just hit the ball and I was focused on
hitting the ball because that was the
most important how I fell or not I
didn't care you you said you were
stopped outside of in the street by some
paparazzi and asked was Cristiano
Ronaldo's bicycle kick goal the best
you've seen and you said yes do you
still think that I was being sarcastic
oh you were yes you meant your not many
understood but I'm not there to explain
that because if you cannot read my mind
it's not my fa so you think yours was
better 100% 100% I said in an interview
later you should try it from 40 m is a
big difference even if his was beautiful
but this was from 40 m
is it is it I've asked I actually asked
him the same question but when you score
a goal like that is it better than
sex I mean in my game that in that game
was crazy because why it was that's what
I wanted to come that's not the answer
yeah but you have to see the whole
package the goal no sex is better come
on my friend sex is better we don't even
go there sex is 10 times better not one
time better 100% is this in case Helena
is watching this yeah no no no no no no
no no sex is better whoever thinks
different he has a problem with his sex
life he should get help but uh would I
never scored a 40 yard bicycle kick so
no you get a lot of adrenaline so after
the goal I saw wilbeck I think he was
the striker and I took off the shirt and
I said enjoy because something like this
he will never see again and he was
watching me so you see even in that
moment I get anger out instead of just
enjoy so I throw it out and I look at
him
actually I was rude but I don't know why
I was rude to him I needed to find OB so
I said enjoy because you will never
enjoy this again but he hasn't done
nothing for me but that's me looking for
it's your natural fight so he's not
personal against him so that's me and he
was watching me he didn't understand
nothing because I have nothing happened
but the game what the goal is why the
goal is most beautiful because of
England because before I came to England
they talk bad because if you haven't
played in Premier League you're not good
enough that's the mentality here which I
respect because they want to see you
challenge your game here and then during
the game they they were calling me the
diva they were calling me a fake Carol
the fans are doing yeah the fans so it
was going on and before that the media
was writing I never score against
England teams in Champions League I
always fail against the english team so
everything this was going around my head
so that's why I say it's a whole package
I score four goals and I don't know I
think F Baston or I have the record
against
England and this was a whole package
because of all the I got that is the
most beautiful goal and it's a goal
England will always remember for the
rest of their life that's true so that
that's why it feels better I personally
think you've scored a better goal okay
and I'm going to tell you I had many
goals that is crazy I'm going to tell
you the one I think is your greatest
goal see what you think this was for ax
against NAC breeda yeah where you
basically terrorized their entire team
their whole team you go through the
whole team and then you score that to me
as a because the bicycle kick is a
brilliantly executed goal no question
but the way you tormented that team for
that goal was really extraordinary yeah
that
was that
was was nasty because often the
beautiful goals is the one the the goals
you will remember is the goals you
cannot repeat that is often I mean a
bicycle kick from 40 Metter maybe you
can repeat maybe you can repeat the drib
because I saw I saw Messi I saw I saw
Maradona half field doing against
England doing these crazy goals and uh
it was a crazy goal but it this is
Instinct these things happen at the
moment this is nothing you plan this is
nothing you you you try to do what's the
best goal you've seen scored by somebody
else the one you wish you'd
scored I think my goals not for my ego
my goals for crazy
goals crazy because I'm 197 and I'm 97
kilos so it's not normal to score these
goals if you have this size but a goal I
would like to score I mean I like the
Zang goal in the final when he with the
left foot cuz it's difficult to repeat
and those goals that you cannot repeat
is the most goals you will remember but
I have top top from top 10 I have maybe
five
goals who is the who is the best player
you've ever seen for me best player is
the one that changed the game the one
that you will go out as a young fan and
you will do what he does for me Ronaldo
phenomenal when he came out was bra
Brazilian was different
because I remember I was young young boy
and um when I saw his
games and on that time we didn't have
digital platform we have we had only
YouTube so we could see on YouTube this
tricks this dribbles these goals so I
remember all of us we we were on YouTube
and YouTube you didn't have even on your
phone you had it on computer so in the
we were in the school we were going in
the how do you say the the room full of
computers and we would go there and
watch YouTube and study the tricks study
the dribbles and uh and we would go out
and try these things and for me he
changed it he was football he he was not
playing he was football because
everybody wanted to be him today I see a
lot of players that score a lot of goals
they they do amazing things but they
don't change the game like he did
because because I don't think they go
out and they do things like the players
do today the Young Generation don't go
out and try to do that when Ronaldo came
they went there and they tried to do
whatever he did so what was totally
different I mean I would say that he was
absolutely Sensational but obviously had
a very short career comparative to say
the other Ronaldo Lionel Messi yourself
in fact the phenomenon has said about
you that he really respects you for the
longevity of your career and I I think
there is a special thing about you Messi
Cristiano Ronaldo the ones who've had
these long long careers that is an
extraordinary achievement isn't it when
so many other
players injuries how you say continuity
yeah I that shows to me it shows to me a
Steely discipline about what you what
you do and a bit of luck you got to be
luck you don't get bad injuries but also
a discipline to do that and a hunger
that you want to keep doing it it's a
big discipline why because you can have
players that had a amazing year and then
falls out you can have players that won
the World Cup then you don't see them
anymore or you don't remember them you
can have players that won the Champions
League and you don't remember them I
didn't win the champions league but they
will remember me I'm not worried but in
the long term you have players that
played 15 20 20 years and they kept that
high level but then we talk different
how long did you last like let's say is
a different different different
situation we talk about when we talk
about the proper player the individual
player obviously we have different
Lifestyles we have different profession
we have different mentality for me I
stopped now three months ago I came to
41 and I still played on top I went to
visit to America I came back normally
you go to America you don't come back
but I went there I came back and I prove
num is age is just an age you can still
play it depending how you take care of
yourself and how you approach things
obviously you need to be intelligent
because the player I was when I was 25
I'm not the same player 35 so if you're
intelligent and you can
manage that situation to change your
game because obviously you have to
change the game I'm I'm not the same
type of player when I was 20 2530 and
you go up you have to play different in
the in the list of alltime great
footballers where do you put
yourself I
mean now I have to speak as a fan
because what are we judged after what we
win Collective what we win individual
I'm talking about individual quality as
players just the skill without winning
anything I think I'm the
best without joking I'm the most
complete player that ever
exists skills and all this if we talk
about I I didn't win the golden bow no I
didn't win I didn't win the Champions
League no if those things matters no I'm
probably not on that list I had the
honor and luck to win 34
trophies and the collective trophies
some individual because the collective
comes the individual comes with the
collective so if the collective does
good the individual will do good so but
when we talk pure only the player the
abilities no I think 100%
not
joking see I I love that about you I
would love every Striker that's ever
played for Arsenal to have that
mentality yeah they had their chance
yeah that you have to discuss with vanar
I'm going to come to that I'm coming
okay okay let me ask you first of all no
but I think it's not about being
arrogant and that I think if selief
surely is confidence backing yourself
but also backing It Up by
I believe it listen I mean you love
Muhammad Ali right wait I will do
another example when I say I am God you
think I'm joking or not you tell me I'm
not joking when I come on the field I
feel like that you feel like God I feel
like God when I'm on the field an
omnipotent I feel Untouchable and I feel
I will smash everyone that comes in my
way that is a mental part let's say
boxing Tyson Fury is the champion if you
ask
me if I could smash I would say yes I
would I would and in my head yes but
when I come in the ring he would knock
me out after two seconds but the
mentality is yes I can yes but in the
ring he would he would eat me alive
without doubts but my mentality is I can
Muhammad Ali said who I know he's one of
your Your Heroes he said if you talk the
talk you've got to walk the walk yeah
100% And he did that you you did that I
mean for all the trash talking and the
boasting and everything thing the truth
is you delivered on the pitch if you
hadn't
done but then you're a clown I agree
you're a clown you don't do that you
have to back up what you say then it's
better to be silent and and not saying
nothing
but but I'm that type of guy I believe
it I have I have a vision and and I will
arrive there and I'm 100% I will because
I'm a winner what do you make of what's
happening in Manchester United they were
the dominant team in the Premier League
for so many years under Sir Alex
Ferguson they've not been able to
replicate that and right now they're
really struggling what what do you put
it down to I remember when I came to
United and uh whoever I met there
everybody was talking about how Fergie
would do it
Ferguson this would not happen with
Ferguson this Ferguson would not do and
I was like listen I don't care what
happened before I'm here to do my own
story my own present time and be
remember for what I did now not for what
he did something I respect that he
brought the club wherever he brought it
the club is because what he did but time
goes on like he the Next Generation and
that and then when I came we won three
Trophies the first year and
uh but I don't know if it's the England
English system or not because above the
coach there was a gap from the coach and
the there was no really football people
between there
so what I was used to we had football
people between there that would come and
smash us when it was bad not giving a
lot of credit when we win because if
they pay you a lot of money you play in
a big Club it's normal to win but I
think now in
United I don't know there's some kind of
how do you say demonstrations about the
owners to sell it and that but just a
reminder the owners are investing it's
not like they're not investing because
they they brought in many players for
high amount of money so T I think it's
it's a little bit wrong saying that
they're not doing what the fans expect
them to do then I don't know what the
real reason is behind everything are the
players under performing I think with
the new
coach the new coach came from where he
was a i i was in ax also Ajax is a
talented Club they have the best talents
in the club they don't have big
stars what is the experience of this
coach young talents he comes to United
United is different mentality different
players so the players there supposed to
be big
stars so I think with his experience
being there I don't know if it talks for
him or not because he he I think he's in
a different situation and then above him
there is a gap where he doesn't get the
help to manage the team listen this is
what I read in the paper so it's not I
have all the situation that H that is
happening but I can just imagine him
coming from Ax to to United is a big
difference because I've been in both
clubs you manage talents up growing is
different kind of approach because there
you have a different kind kind of
discipline you come to United you you do
the same thing I don't know I don't
believe and I don't think it's the same
treatment you give I mean Cristiano
Ronaldo when he gave the interview to me
when he left United he said that he felt
he didn't have the respect of Eric ten
hog you see with Jaden Sancho now a
similar situation tenal criticizing him
in public and so on maybe that is an
illustration of his of his problems in
managing big talent but I don't I don't
say it's the coach fault because
experience you cannot buy you just have
to get time to get the experience but
it's two different situation being in
Ajax being united then if it's his fault
I don't think because I think everybody
has a responsible in the whole situation
we are a piece of puzle from the big
puzle so everybody have uh a
responsibility to do and to to fulfill
the the the demands United has to win
they the they have to win every title
they play for now they're being
dominated by the neighbors and uh and
it's a totally different situation there
and uh you need to find the right path
again and to to push for that now
it's I think it's you need a plan you
need a project to follow and it feels
like you follow a project plan and then
it goes wild in a moment because of the
results either you believe in it or you
don't believe in it so but with the
thing situation of the coach I think
he's living two different situations now
then obviously what happened with Sancho
and and Cristiano I don't know because
is he do you think he's out of his depth
a bit ten
hog I think he needs more time to get
the experience how to handle a team but
you don't really get time at a club
likeit no obviously not because we need
to win that's the reality you come to my
when I was in Milan I cannot give you
time to to develop to to to perform you
need to perform straight because like I
said survival mode it's you or another
one because United is in a situation you
don't do good enough the next day there
is another one and the result speaks for
itself so that's why that is tricky but
how much time do you give a coach I
don't know depends of the owners what
they want but if you listen to the fans
you don't have a lot of time because
they want to win absolutely and I
understand them because they're used to
win and they want to still win so
so I think it's a lot of things the
small details often makes the difference
it's not the the the whole the big
pictures you see because when things are
good there were there are still errors
and problems but you don't see it
because we are winning did you feel when
you were at United one of the things
Cristiano suggested to me was the
younger players didn't really show him
the respect he was expecting that when
he was a young player at United when he
was 18 He hung on every word of ke and
Neville and skols and all these guys
that because players now get paid so
much more money that they don't have the
same respect for the older players they
used to did did you find that but
respect is nothing you ask for respect
is something you take so it depends on
you I have to make sure you respect me
it's nothing you ask for you don't ask
the young guys for respect you take the
respect and you put them in the place
then the situation that they earn more
money yes they earn much more money for
doing so so little compared to before
before before you needed to do much more
to come to sign a piece of contract and
to get what you
deserve under the circumstances of that
situation now you you see a lot
of the new generation they fly very fast
without even walking so walking is
performing for me
so it's up to him to make sure they
respect you if it was me and he don't
respect me that young player is the last
thing he would have in his life cuz I
would make sure he respect me and he
would know it for the rest of his life
so it's up to him to make sure they
respect
him one of your great friends is noat
jovic yeah and he's I mean he's an
extraordinary dedicated Supreme athlete
a champion what what do you make of him
as a sportsman never mind as a tennis
player I think he
I think he's an amazing amazing example
for what he's doing we have different
philosophies and uh he has all these
things he he does to to perform and
it and for for him doing that he's doing
an individual sport I was doing a
collective sport I think he's a vegan
he's a vegan he does this things getting
energy G from different kind of things
I'm not 100% in it I'm opposite I mean I
don't do that I am
more those things doesn't change me I
change my own game you tell me good luck
I don't need luck to perform I decide
when to perform good I am in control to
do good or bad that is what I believe I
don't need to knock wood three times to
go out and it brings me luck I decided
who are the sporting champions in
history that you most relate to I mean
Muhammad Ali for me was because my
father has had these old tapes black and
white the big cassettes how do you call
it tapes VHS I yeah and he was a big fan
of boxing because his brother was a
boxer and I was watching all these
boxing fights and uh and movies but the
movies was Bruce Lee Jackie Chan so my
whole world was like doing all these
crazy movements but at the same time I
was playing football so I tried to bring
it in in my game for me Muhammad Ali was
the greatest sportman ever
because because as I feel today the
sportman tries to be as perfect as
possible he wants to have the perfect
image he wants not to say wrong in a
interview he's afraid to say certain
things um he's afraid to to cross the
red light on the street h so it's like
afraid that somebody would judge him in
a wrong way Muhammad Ali was not that
Muhammad Ali was himself and he was
himself in the ring outside the ring and
I think it's important because if you
create an image of yourself that is not
you I mean let's talk about charity we
do charity things but you do it to have
a image or you do it because you really
want to do it I do a lot of things but I
don't want to be seen
because I do it from my heart because I
really want to do it but I see other
ones do it and then they go in the media
I donate 1 million to a hospital I open
a school for children I did this but if
you do those things you don't have to be
seen because a third person has to say
to you oh what a lovely guy you are
you're such amazing guy no I don't need
that I do it because I want to do it not
to get an image that I think today in
this sport world they're looking they're
focusing too much on their image instead
of being who you are people have to
accept you for who you are and that is
important when you see the the top
Strikers of today earling harand yeah
kilan mbappe what do you think of those
guys I think they're both amazing I
think Holland is very intelligent in the
way he's playing he doesn't touch the
ball more than he needs to I see he has
this Killer Instinct even if he has the
hattrick he still wants to score the
fourth goal
fifth goal and I think he's in the
perfect environment and
uh is there more to do for him I don't
know what is more for him to do if you
say to him to get better what is that
from three goals to six goals from 6 to
n so is he maximum out of what he is
because what you expect from him is
goals so if you don't get goals you will
say he didn't have a good day mbappe is
more of a complete player he can do more
things than Holland he can do the
unexpected he will do things that you
will react wow he reminds of Ronaldo the
phenomenal the
Brazilian and he would do things that
other ones cannot do can he get better
yes he can get much better much much
better so he just need to focus on
football that's the only thing he needs
to do you said about yourself I can't
help but laugh at how perfect I am yeah
you don't see it
[Laughter]
is there any
perfect looking sharp I went to buy told
me for you you made you cost me €3,000
you know what it was worth it you're
looking sharp thank you thank you but is
there any
imperfection I mean I had moments where
criticize yourself what would you what
would you
choose I
mean for me the confidence is is
bulletproof I have a strong confidence
uh I would not
go and have complex on myself and do and
say I need to fix this this obviously I
could do certain things but I am who I
am I cannot change that I was created by
my parents and I became and I
look the way I do
so for me that is perfection because I
cannot CH I have a big nose yeah I have
a big nose I have a space between the
blah blah blah but that's who I am I
cannot change I don't want to change
because you should believe and in who
you are because you are perfect then if
you like it you don't like it the second
one like it but I'm not here to be to be
judged by other ones I judge myself and
the way I judge myself I have no
complainings I am
perfect so that's the way I think and
that's the way I do things and that's
the way I am then if I critize ize
myself yes I could do things better I
could speak English better I could do my
game better it's that's how I CRI but if
I hear some third
person say something Fu he's not
important for me he has more problems
than me probably that's why he's judging
me so we all have our Our Own Story
let's say but I'm good I'm good about
myself I'm not worried there's only one
thing you got
wrong oh no I'm telling you what it is
there's one thing you got wrong so it's
your birthday next week right will have
just before this show end and there's
one big mistake you made in your I know
already what you will say what am I
going to say because I I didn't go to
Arsenal yes you see first of I predict
future first of all tell me why you
didn't join ARS when you were 17 so when
I was young I had a lot of interest from
a lot of clubs and one of them was
Arsenal so I came to the office of Mr
aren vaner and was was big hype because
I saw these players be Camp HRI I saw
yungb I saw
Vieira I saw all these players and I was
like this is this is big because these
players I see in TV even if I already
played in high level Sweden but this was
big because this was like I am here now
last week I was playing PlayStation with
these guys and I spoke with vanar and he
has this French he he was tall I didn't
expect him to be so tall I come in his
office and we speak and yeah and he was
like what do you want he wanted to get
to know me to feel me because I think he
is a type of person he just don't buy
the play he wants to know what he's
buying I think and yeah and then in the
end he had Arsenal shirt with number
nine and uh he want you to come and do a
trial for two weeks and from all this
everything was good until until he said
you come and do a trial and I was
looking at him
obviously he's V I'm nobody in that
moment said don't do trials and he was
like what do you
mean I don't do trials either you want
me or you don't want me or else why am I
here like that was my but it was not to
play a game it was me no but you have to
come and do a trial and that no no you
don't understand I don't do trials and
that's was it I didn't I never went to
Arsenal well and then I yeah this story
breaks my heart right cuz you would have
been fantastic at you are exactly the
kind of Striker we need right now I can
tell you we would win a lot of trophies
I'm 100% true we would have won even
more tro but I also know I can tell from
your face it's a big regret of yours
okay you wish if you had a good time
again so this is your birthday present
okay thank it is uh Ibrahimovic wow nice
number 11 it looks good looks sharp I
think it's your size and you know what
it's never too late you can come out of
retirement thank you slip it on looks
good right thank you thank you very much
H it was a great interview nice meeting
you a real pleasure finally to do it
you're everything I hoped you would be
thank you thank you very much thank
you